we want everyone to experience the magic
of new york style pizza
and it is magic world famous in fact
so here to show us how to make the
perfect pizza at home
is literally one of the biggest stars
in the chef world who are rock stars
let's face that
it's amber red
oh my god there's so much love in this
room i want to just live here
good come look i'll cook for you every
single day if you'd like me to
and i will be your student and i want
you to
drive this segment how can you teach us
to do this me and jill where are your
girls
well today i'm going to show you guys a
little bit how to do
and give you some tips for making a
great pie at home so
i mean you know sometimes people get a
little freaked out about like
pizza dough do i have to make it you can
totally buy pizza dough
at the store and usually it comes frozen
so my tip for using that kind of
purchased pizza dough
let it defrost let it come to room
temperature and i like sort of a thin
a thinner sort of pizza so my springtime
pie that i'm doing
is hashtag springtime pie a springtime
pie we have
um asparagus prosciutto a little fontina
so just make sure that it's like a nice
even thin layer you can use your
fingertips to kind of push it out
a little bit and kind of stretch it and
then make sure you preheat
your oven so pizzas cook hard and fast
and out at a high temperature hashtag
hard and fast
right hard high and fast that's how we
like it it's daytime tv
and well you know a little afternoon
delight dear
um a hashtag you know if you
don't if we're not lucky enough to have
a pizza oven
i recommend buying a pizza stone because
that will help
the the dough on the bottom create a
nice crisp
crunch to your dough and not
so when you're going to to put your
toppings on your pizza
i like a liberal coating so cheese is
like a nice
even coating i find if you sprinkle it
from a little higher
it's easier to get it like a more even
coating and then i have some asparagus
give
those a liberal sprinkling
um and so then we would just put this
into your preheated oven
and then when it comes out of the oven
we top it with a little bit of
prosciutto
and then we just give a little sprinky
dink of the arugula on the done pie
i'll try this yes oh my god oh my god
so good
damn oh my god i'm getting flavors i
never get normally from pizza right
the freshness of the asparagus and the
arugula is so unprecedented the salt
from the prosciutto i know i should chew
but i can't
and this is amazing so are you jill
i love you i love you and i just want to
thank jill and anne the new season of
worst cooks in america premieres on the
food network
on april 25th
[Music]